daniel guillerme bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france on le disait à vous
demander un élargissement de la
compétence des infirmiers infirmières
sur quel constat aujourd'hui vous fait
cette demande
écouter aujourd'hui on voit qu'il ya des
difficultés d'accès sur les territoires
d'accès aux soins sur les territoires à
dax et notamment aux médecins traitants
l'idée n'est pas évidemment de remplacer
je voudrais rassurer nos amis médecin
n'est pas de remplacer les médecins mais
cette fluidifier les parcours patient à
l'échelle des territoires en accordant
des prérogatives plus importante aux
infirmières qui elle en fait my le
territoire de manière assez serré
aujourd'hui il y à 130 mille infirmières
libérales sur le territoire il n'y a pas
de désert
infirmer ces infirmières se sont
organisés pour faire face à une
continuité des soins puisqu'elles
prennent des patients en charge du lundi
au dimanche et 24 heures sur 24 donc il
faudrait s'appuyer sur ce tissu libéral
pour effectivement pas lié aux déserts
médicaux là où effectivement les
difficultés d'accès sont prégnants donc
je le répète pas question de remplacer
les médecins les médecins en leurs
compétences et leur niveau d'études et
on va pas faire de pseudo médecin avec
des infirmiers mais en tout état de
cause l'idée est de faciliter les choses
de permettre aux médecins de dégager du
temps médical utiles afin effectivement
que les patients puissent accéder en
tout cas au système dans des délais qui
soient aujourd'hui raisonnable alors
justement des compétences nouvelles
jusque là réservés aux médecins qu'elle
sont elles très précisément ces
nouvelles compétences que vous demandez
nous souhaiterions en fait investir
deschamps comme la présente une
valorisation en tout cas la prévention
et de l'éducation thérapeutique mais
aujourd'hui force est de constater
qu'une fois que le diagnostic médical
est posée
la question qu'il faut se poser c'est
que y'a t'il besoin d'un médecin pour
assurer le suivi de ces patients là on a
un double défi à relever au niveau du
système de santé c'est l'explosion des
maladies chroniques et le vieillissement
de la population et en constatant qu'il
faut dix ans pour former un médecin
aujourd'hui on n'aura pas en fait deux
lution avant une dizaine d'années
en othe gras dans le métier d'infirmière
on pourrait en tout cas gagné entre sept
et huit ans au niveau de cette
organisation et ses prises en charge eh
bien vous rajoutez des tâches
supplémentaires des tâches qui vous
engage en plus alors que vous lisiez
vous avez déjà un agenda bien fourni
quotidien ça va pas vous rajouter
justement encore plus de travail
on serait on a en fait une le secteur le
secteur libéral en tout cas infirmiers
connaît une
croissance démographique est assez
importante mais qui est lié à ce qu'on
appelle le virage ambulatoire
de plus en plus de patients en fait sont
prises en charge à domicile donc on a en
fait un dynamisme démographique de la
profession
est aujourd'hui les professionnels
seraient en mesure de prendre en charge
de nouveaux patients avec effectivement
un hub à 9 gras d'âge entre guillemets
qui concernerait toute la chaîne de
soins
il s'agit pas en fait de raisonner de
manière corporatistes et uniquement à
l'aune de notre métier à nous et je
pense qu'il faut qu'on travaille avec
les médecins généralistes avec les
infirmières en pratique avancée avec les
aides-soignantes avec un objectif en
fait il faut qu'on partage c'est
d'améliorer l'accès en soi puisque le
problème le plus prégnant aujourd'hui et
bien cet accès aux soins à l'échelle des
territoires
justement c'est le noeud du problème
c'est la question de ces déserts
médicaux aujourd'hui qu'en est il
justement de ya de moins en moins de
médecins on sait dans les campagnes
on voit les les communes rurales
notamment à qui sont toutes à la
recherche de médecins elles veulent
installer des médecins on sait
pertinemment qu'on ne pourra pas avoir
un médecin au pied de chaque mairie
maintenant il faut travailler sur la trt
l'attractivité du métier bien sûr de
médecins généralistes et de médecin
traitant
on est nous complètement favorable à ce
qu'il y ait en fait une valorisation
de la consultation médicale et on
méditera avec des médecins que cette
consultation soit valorisée à condition
effectivement que c'est que ces
consultations
concernant fait des
patients qui sont complexes et qui
nécessitent en tout cas la mobilisation
de compétences médicales alors on le
sait la question des déserts médicaux
c'est un problème qui dure depuis des
années que l'on pensait résoudre avec la
construction de maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires
ça n'a pas été efficace finalement
écouté il faut il faut regarder les
chiffres en fait de manière lucide
aujourd'hui la totalité de l'offre de
soins au niveau des maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires si à peu près entre
entre 12 et 15% donc ça veut dire que
quand on s'occupe des maisons de santé
pluridisciplinaires
on laisse de côté 85 % de l'offre de
soins donc là aujourd'hui ce qu'on dit
nous pouvoirs publics en tout cas une
manière très claire c'est qu'il faut
embarquer tout le monde est calme qu'à
se focaliser en fait sur une seule
solution n'apportera pas en tout cas on
va ne va pas résoudre les problèmes
auxquels on est confrontés et aient eu
les médecins qu'est-ce qui vous disent
par rapport à cette question des
compétences nouvelles que vous demandez
ils seraient plutôt favorables ou alors
plutôt réticents
on va ouvrir bien sûr un dialogue avec
avec les organisations de médecins on
voit très bien qu'il ya des crispations
en fait au niveau des médecins m'ont l'a
vu lors de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale en
fin d'année
notamment sur l'accès direct des
patients ou kinésithérapeutes
orthophonistes orthoptistes
nous ce qu'on a envie de leur dire celle
n'ayez pas peur l'idée n'est pas de
substituer des compétences infirmières
des as des as des compétences médicales
l'idée est de compléter et d'aider nos
amis médecins qui aujourd'hui ont des
difficultés effectivement à faire face à
la demande
le ministère de la santé d'ailleurs va
ouvrir un chantier sur cette question là
qu'est ce qu'il en est
heureux c'est un chantier qui devait
être ouvert normalement en janvier 2021
la crise sanitaire a reporté en fait
d'ouverture on a vu un colloque en fait
la semaine dernière
dans quel le ministre de la santé a
déclaré qu'il allait ouvrir même avec du
retard
les le chantier de la réingénierie du
diplôme d'état d'aide-soignant nous
concevons 10 et on a un petit peu envie
de le prendre au mot puisque il est il
nous a dit qu'il était prêt à aller très
loin donc on va voir si effectivement ce
ne sont pas des déclarations d'affichage
et quelque part ce qu'on lui dit c'est
chiche
merci daniel guillerme d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce matin dans la
matinale de rtl france je le rappelle
vous êtes président de la fédération
nationale des infirmiers